more breaking news surrounding the
unequal standard of justice and how the
fbi has been politicized the doj has
been weaponized and politicized under
joe biden we'll have full exclusive
coverage you won't believe tonight's new
details we have major new polls tonight
in key midterm matchups that will
determine control of the united states
senate a new poll for example has
hershel walker up in the state of
georgia and we will do the job that the
mob and the media will never do we will
vet all of these far left extreme
candidates tonight that will be rafael
warnock that's coming up but first
tonight just breaking now a major new
report from the washington times it just
broke it says rank and file fbi
whistleblowers coming forward many are
now saying that director christopher
wray has lost control of the agency and
needs to resign according to the
washington times report these
whistleblower claims include allegations
of bias even being forced to sign false
affidavits and according to my sources
tonight who i spoke to within the last
hour
that are directly involved with the
whistleblowers there are at now at least
20 confirmed whistleblowers that have
come forward and according to their
attorney quote i'm hearing from fbi
personnel that they feel like the
director has lost control of the bureau
he said they are saying how does this
guy survive he's leaving he's got to
leave now also breaking tonight a new
memo from the attorney general merrick
garland and his office they're sending a
stern reminder
this night to staff about policies that
limit contact with members of congress
by the way that would mean fbi members
talking to members of congress as
whistleblowers
so this letter obviously a convenient
reminder from the attorney general of
the united states so the question is is
he trying to silence these
whistleblowers because it certainly
looks like it at this hour now it also
looks like they're trying to pressure
these whistleblowers but what democrats
they only like hearsay whistleblowers
not real whistleblowers that sounds like
intimidation directly from the ag's
office and the ag and the fbi director
need to encourage whistleblowers not
silence them not intimidate them this
sounds like a veiled threat let me
remind you of the policy about talking
to congress or what or else what
you get fired for identifying corruption
and abuse of power when they should be
applauded if it's true now all of this
comes following a major report last
night where top fbi agent tim tebow was
reportedly escorted out of the
washington field office on friday by two
or three other agents accused of quote
political bias in handling the
investigation of hunter biden's computer
laptop and now tebow through his lawyer
is now pushing back against the report
among growing scrutiny of his conduct
and while joe biden claims to care about
law and order while he continues to
completely ignore this two-tiered system
of justice the blatant political bias
and corruption inside the fbi the doj
his fbi his doj take a look
i'm opposed to defunding the police i'm
also opposed to defunding the fbi
look
there's no greater responsibility for
government than ensuring the safety of
our people
when hunter's home gets raided i hope he
feels the same way here on this program
we want to be very clear we condemn all
threats and all attacks on law
enforcement not when it's just
politically convenient as a matter of
fact on this program for the rank and
file the 95 98 99
we are very grateful for all the good
fbi uh agents and employees that risk
their lives to keep us safe we support
them now but the fbi is not immune from
oversight and they're not immune from
criticism and they're not immune from
having bad apples or being called out
for massive agency-wide failures and the
failures inside especially the upper
echelon of the fbi now also breaking
tonight we're now learning that amid
growing scrutiny of the fbi and the doj
that the department is now banning
political appointees from partisan
events
but i'm sorry that just isn't good
enough fbi director ray and attorney
general garland now they have done a
disservice director ray knew there were
problems with the upper echelon of the
fbi
when he took over
he should have taken what should be
the world's premier law enforcement
agency and he should have cleaned up the
politics in the fbi he didn't do it and
now things are worse with merrick
garland because he seems to be
weaponizing the doj the biden doj and
getting away with everything has now led
to more politics or politicizing of the
fbi which by the way i predicted would
happen many times on this program if we
didn't hold the people that abused fisa
warrants and used hillary clinton's
bought and paid for dossier and lied to
fisa court judges not once but four
times to spy on a presidential candidate
and a president or as the wall street
journal editorial board pointed out why
is there one standard for hillary
clinton and one standard for donald
trump remember this is now a doj that
appears hell-bent on finding anything
they can use against the 45th president
we saw that in the warrant and the raid
at mar-a-lago but it is the same
organization that let hillary clinton
off the hook for mishandling a ton of
top secret classified materials on
unsecured private servers because even
jim comey acknowledged crimes were
committed but no reasonable prosecutor
he said would bring a case the same
people that let her get away with clear
obstruction of justice she deleted 33
000 emails remember we learned about
something called bleach bit and then
devices were destroyed with hammers hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else